hey guys this is des offender thing here
I'm David Griffin your resident comic
book and video game guru and this is our
review of the walking dead season 4
episode 3 isolation okay so the big
thing that gets revealed it in this
episode I didn't actually get to see oh
yes I you tweeted yeah like your TV your
DVR cut off when I DVR recorder the
walking dead did not get maybe the last
30 seconds a minute I don't know if you
guys have time or don't ever get time
water they're terrible and so I didn't
see it I post on Facebook hey guys right
what happened at the end I saw Rick
talking to Carol and then it cuts off
well Carol admitted to the people fill
you in yes okay she admitted to killing
burning the two bodies okay yeah she'd
made it to it a great Rick asked her
because he knows he knows and she just
doesn't matter of fact but she's like
yeah then just kinda looked at him and
walked away like that was it enough
enough said then the I'm so just credits
roll after that credits roll yeah yeah
she says that matter of factly but if
you watch the episode you'll see there
certain like this where she Tyrese comes
and asks her to look after Sasha right
you know you'll see here kind of
breakdown after I leave pushes over the
water which you know see it bothers her
yes it bothers her but I think she's the
whole walking that mentality as you
gotta do what you gotta do and that's
the whole mentality of the series so how
do you feel about Carol cuz you know she
started off as a character that that
seemed pretty weak in season one it just
grown through like a steady she didn't
rush it like Andrew Ellis felt like she
was trying to rush like right like this
badass word no Carol it seems like it's
more progressing at a realistic and
steady pace and now she's gotten to this
point where now she's willing to burn
the bodies but the question is is did
she kill them and burn them were they
already turned and oh yeah exactly I
mean I think she's doing used to be done
I think I mean Rick's done some dark
things you know I mean we have a comic
said he obviously does some pretty
horrible things I mean everybody does
what they need to do to survive I think
she's doing that I think she is probably
the most well developed character on the
show maybe because of her progression
she came from this woman who's getting
abused by
husband to you know this I don't know
mothering type yeah she stay here with
it kids and I should with Darrell I
don't know what that's about but you
know like all this stuff is kind of gone
on and she's yeah she's a great she's a
welder I'm fine with this I'm fine with
it seems reasonable but now there's
gonna be problems I mean oh I mean thing
you talk about Carol and Daryl rhyming
names um but Daryl's the one who told KY
Reese we're gonna find out who did this
and I'm gonna put a bull in their hair
right yeah he's gonna put a bullet go
ahead I think it's just gonna be one of
those I think Daryl find out by think I
don't like Tyrese to find out right away
that might come into play maybe later on
the episode later on the season I'm
sorry down the road a little like Rick
and Derek and find out there and keep it
under wraps right exactly yeah don't I
mean Rick already found out by me he's
gonna tell Daryl and they're gonna try
and decide what because really it's Rick
and Daryl show yeah I mean they're
running what hair is right in that whole
camp uh and also i just i think that
that dynamic between like because Tyrese
is not gonna be happy no he's a thing we
do they made him really angry in this
isn't angry dude it won't kill like this
is the car just just twitching like he's
just twitching the car you know he's
gonna come on just felt like he fought
Rick and Daryl yeah in the beginning and
then Rick went all crazy right off and
then later he kind of calmed down but
still was upset yeah yeah and then yeah
that's scene where he was in the card he
wouldn't get out no he's just sitting
there he's just twitching he says he
knew his building up he was gonna get
mad a lot of people humping on the web
this is like kind of reenacting the
famous scene from vol 3 which I have
here safety behind bars for those of you
trying to catch up this is kind of
backtracking the scenes a little bit
different in the comic the scene is when
he goes into the gymnasium and he's
trapped in there with like all these it
in the prison he's trapped in with all
these zombies you don't think is gonna
get out and of course it later on they
show that he does get out so this was
kind of reenacting that scene paying
tribute to that a little bit different
way he's out in the open of course doing
it this time but yeah I mean he's he's a
badass I mean I said to me I thought it
was gonna be a goner yeah he was getting
swarmed and swarmed and then Darrell um
guy from the wire oh yeah yeah
Bob cuz I heard he's like I heard
Darrell's like and then Bob but Bob yeah
okay let's say for for this review we
call him Bob mambazo Michonne Daryl and
Bob take off without area and I was like
alright Tyrece is goner and that's how
it is kind of in this book too but it's
just a little bit difference inside the
prison instead so he showed that he is
he's a tough guy himself yeah and then
we kind of don't know what's happening
with them cuz now they don't have their
car anymore right you know they still
need to get the anti-biotics they're on
the run there's a lot of zombies around
it yes a lot of them yeah I mean it just
keeps going I mean it's just every weeks
mo drama I mean it's every week now is
kind of like how are they gonna get out
of this situation you know is what this
is kind of training to which is fine I
mean you know it's well yeah the main
thing is still the flu right the flu
yeah I originally had said that the same
person must have burned the body those
feeding the zombies but now it doesn't
look like that there's no reason care I
doubt you thought right but it makes
sense that maybe of why she burnt the
bodies right some people in the comment
section mentioned that they think it's
the little girl yeah well the
relationship you know blonde girl yeah
hmm so I don't know well back to the
whole flu thing I really just hope it
doesn't last too long yeah you know we
got Glenn sick now like I'm like no you
can't you get kill like the only like
asian guy on the show got out of
diversity I'm for the replacement if you
go yeah oh no I yeah I mean I just hope
it doesn't drag out it's like a lot of
things in the show I mean one thing I've
talked about a lot here is I prefer the
way the comic moves I understand for
budget reasons they can't even they
can't go from place to place all the
time it's like you know the show's got a
budget but i think the comic moves a
little bit better pace like they have
these scenes in the prison but they also
they move you know they go from
different place I think I desormie get
stuck here they had this huge group of
people that would sort really know that
much about I mean from you know where
the governor was you know in the town so
I hope we kind of get a lot more
explanation to what those people are up
solely by the mid season right finale
then they somehow get pushed out of the
present yeah see some different also
they're gonna cut down
they're not bringing no like 20-30
people that they have too much people
are gonna start to die and now we I mean
I know kind of going off track a little
bit but I mean we also know that there
is they are developing a spin-off show
yeah and curtains excited because he's
never had a chance just from a comic to
tell a different point of view from
another area of the country's yeah
supposedly West Coast West Coast so I
mean I'll be curious see what that's
gonna be like you know more more walking
dead more zombies more tough living this
is tough living in this world tough wood
and then Tyree see you know already
dealing with his girlfriend's that now
his sister stasek yeah uh do you think
she's a goner I I think she's gonna
survive hmm but I think Herschel's gonna
be a goner probably yeah i was gonna ask
what you thought about him in the woods
you know with Karl would you think of
that moment you know just I mean I think
it's fun I think he's it's almost like
he's accepted or wanting death I mean he
goes in there with a doctor he's
basically gets like blood spit on and
he's just like I'll just take off my
thing with my face and just almost seems
like he's accepted it he's ready to go I
me in a nice little speech with you know
with the Rick and his daughter Maggie
saying like hey you know every time we
go out and we risk our lives and some
like there's always been kind of the ob
one of the I mean he's the wise sage
that you know he just kind of gives
advice you know I mean it's let's please
Ben somehow he's got his elderberry tea
formula that helps like keep the flu
from killing people right verily I mean
yeah I don't know I don't know I keep
its always arted me to talk about the
show and week from we because i'm not
sure where the seasons go i don't know
what their goal is I mean again that's
just something you have to let the wait
and find out so I don't know I wanted to
move past the flu thing though I play
antagonist I think that's it maybe
that's it there's just nothing besides
the zombies but they're always if this
has always been the greatest thing about
the walking dead you know from the comic
and everything else is the zombies are
more of a backdrop well they were like
that force of nature right like a
disaster right hurricane or earthquake
or something they're the thing that's
right the danger that's present but
they're not you know we have no
motivation there you know they're just
killing people because they want to eat
the flesh but they don't they don't like
oh we we don't like those people or
let's take what they have it ready just
there's doing what they're supposed to
be doing the last season we had the
governor who did a good job but I think
since that Stroh is never really
resolved I think everything from season
three entities are you still hanging on
this season and it needs to somehow find
a way to move past that I'm not sure how
well they need to bring the governor
back like a short story line with him
yeah don't drag them off right yeah
exactly cuz that's what I thought we
thought was gonna happen at the end of
season yeah but that's not everybody one
this big epic he's in finale just it
just didn't deliver so yeah they needed
they need to resolve that we do you
think about Carl tagging along with
herschel in the woods still seems a
little gun happy little trigger-happy
what's that yeah always shoot stuff it's
tough of kids I mean he's pouting you
know is like I was like I won't be stuck
with kids little kids like he's so
growing up and tuck it I think and it's
not that it's not the actors falses
before but I mean he's just grown up
these hit the stage as a kid the actor
has grown up too fast and the comic he
still feels like a little kid he's got a
little kids so but he still wears the
hat I mean I still wears I had
anticipated where's the Hat he just he
just feels too old to me so he's I don't
know he's coming off more of an
adolescent now than a little kid anymore
that's not it's not his fault icity and
the comic they can keep them young they
can draw them any age they one chance is
growing up so I don't know Carl's Carl
yeah they stuff it wants to be gornath
let's be like his daddy wants to be the
leader and then or anything about like
with Michonne and Daryl remember cuz
Darrell's like oh you're run off again
yeah and she's like what are you talking
about well I think Daryl when he first
won the group felt like an outsider I
think Darrell and mashona maybe had a
little bit of a bond because nah
Michonne I mean she's not an outsider
anymore but didn't think she still feels
that way no no nobody wants to see her
go she's tough data well Darrell and
Michonne are the two badasses exactly
yeah I can't leave be awful alright guys
so that's what we thought the episode
you can post your comments below on the
website or on our YouTube channel that's
a think Carol pro make sure you
subscribe to that channel welcome child
us on twitter i can find Dennis and I at
think hero personally i'm at griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
a facebook.com slash think Carol fans
and make sure you like that pay
to take our video and share it on
Twitter Facebook and all that stuff so
and you can always chat with us
you